everyone and welcome to today's live
webinar genome editing for functional
genomics and drug discovery presented by
Aetna
Leben Cara a senior staff scientist at
cell biology Rd at Thermo Fisher
Scientific and Sanjay Kumar is scientist
at Thermo Fisher Scientific I'm Suzy
Valdez and I'll be your moderator for
this educational webinar presented by
lab routes and sponsored by thermo
Fisher Scientific before we begin I'd
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located at the
lower left of the presentation window
type your questions into the box that
appear on the screen and we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
also notices reviewing the presentation
in a slide window to enlarge that window
just click on the screen icon located on
the lower right if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation click
on the support button at the top right
of the presentation window or use that
Q&A button and let us know you're having
a problem I'd now like to introduce
today's speakers chetna revin Carr and
Sanjeev Kumar beginning with chetna
revin car Sedna is a senior staff
scientist at Thermo Fisher Scientific
with over 15 years of experience in the
field of cell biology and has been with
the company for 10 years before joining
the Services team she led the
development of several new products
ranging from cell based assays for GPCR
back mem based assays to 3d cellular
models as a technical lead on services
team she supported project designs and
execution her experience covers a broad
range of applications from cell
engineering to disease modeling our
second speaker today is sanjay kumar
previous to his concurrent tenure as a
scientist in the synthetic biology
business of thermo Fisher Scientific
Sanjay Kumar accumulated more than 10
years of experience studying the
cellular response to DNA damage that
work began with Sanjay's pursuit of his
doctorate degree resulting in his PhD
from the cancer genetics department at
Roswell Park Cancer Institute in Buffalo
New York at Roswell
Sanji identified the mechanism of
replication forks low down upon DNA
damage and fishing yeast he worked in
the DNA damage field continued with
postdoctoral research at Caltech in
Pasadena California where he dissected
the role of the risk 1 protein in the
vertebrae interests Bayes checkpoint
additionally Sanjay holds a business
degree in bioscience management with a
Keck private Institute as part of the
scientific team at Thermo Fisher
Scientific he has contributed to the
commercial development of genome editing
tools such as talons and crispers most
recently he played a key role in the
development of the gene art
crispier nucleus mRNA and supporting
early access to gene art platinum cast
nine as well as true cut cash 9v too
currently he's a leader of cell
engineering group within customs
services team his role requires Sanji to
lead several custom cell engineering
projects and streamline adapt these
workflows for a variety of applications
please join me now in welcoming
chetna robin car and Sanjeev Kumar I
will now turn the presentation over to
them welcome to both of you
thank you hello and welcome to the
genome editing for function genomics and
drug discovery webinar our webinar today
is divided into two parts first part
will be focused on genome editing to
generate suitable cellular models and
the second part will be the using these
cellular models to ask biological
questions without offer without further
ado let's jump in for the first part we
will be looking at using genome editing
tools primarily CRISPR to generate
suitable cellular models genome editing
workflow is a simple three step workflow
which can be very simply summarized as
the three DS designed deliver and detect
for designing portion one is to identify
what gene they want to target identify
the correct target size and then design
appropriate editing tools for delivery
of course once we have designed the two
we need to deliver it and we need to
deliver it with the best possible
efficiency once design and delivery are
completed we need to understand the
efficiency of genome editing tool that
was delivered into the cells its
efficiency and the type of modifications
that were made into the genome by this
tool and that's the detect portion I
will be going over designed and
delivered portions rather rapidly but
there are full on-demand webinars
available on these topics at the thermo
Fisher website you are very much welcome
to go and check those out to take the
complications and all the work out of
design portion thermo Fisher has
generated a full library of pre-designed
crispers against all the coding genes in
human and mouse genome so how did we do
that we basically identified all the
coding genes in human and mouse genome
and then identified which transcripts
which crispers will be able to knock out
all the transcripts of a particular gene
identified all those crispers and then
these crispers were filtered and scored
through several different criteria which
involve the GC content presence of a
proto spacer adjacent motif or Pam which
is usually n GG sequence then sequence
preference nucleotide positioning and
several other criteria plus a lot of
bench experience that we have generated
went into making the scoring criteria
that were used to make these data base
after going through all of that we went
and looked at the top scoring guide RNAs
and those are presented in our online
tool that just move on to the next step
deliver alright so we have identified
which genes we want to target and which
format of CRISPR we want to use then we
deliberate currently the best format for
crispers is the cash nine RNP format
which is a guide RNA either individual
transcribed or synthetic version coupled
to the true cut cash 9v to protein as I
would
to a protein complex can be delivered
into self to achieve maximum maximum
editing the Casman RMP can be delivered
into cells using two methods first is an
electroporation based method using the
in vitro jhin's neon transaction system
in case you don't have that easily
available you can also use the light
perfect Amin CRISPR Maps reagent and
during this talk today we will be using
CRISPR naturally agent during our case
study in cases where you have a large
library of crispers to screen in those
situations lentiviral methods come in
quite handy and in the later part of the
talk we will be looking at use of Lenti
or a cache line coupled with plenty
array crispers for a large screen large
scale screen and we will get there later
for now let's just look at what is the
next step next step is detection so we
have designed and delivered the crispers
delivered them into the cells and then
how do we detect them there are two
simple ways to detect the editing
outcomes one is a gel-based mismatch
detection as say which i will be going
on going through and second is the DNA
sequencing based method after going
through these two methods we will be
looking into a case study of generating
a real cell line through transfection
clonal isolation on an off target
analysis alright so we have made a
crisper and for every
situation we usually recommend that a
user design at least three crispers for
a given target ask them to identify the
one with the highest efficiency at the
target site once that is done we need to
validate the Edit in the pool of
transfected cells and ask for element
biological questions whether that
whether the modification was homozygous
or heterozygous which one was desired
whether we got any insertion deletion
with the result in frame shapes and if
we were looking for any donor DNA based
replacements did we actually achieve
homology directed repair so in order to
address all of these questions we go to
the detect portion so first is the gel
base mismatch detection assay it's also
called the genomic cleavage detection
assay it's a very simple only for our
workflow from start to finish to us to
address the question whether there was
any genomic editing in the transfected
pool so as we know delivery of a genome
editing tool into the deer into the
cells will lead to genomic cleavage
shown here by scissors so DNA double
strand breaks caused by the genome
editing tool usually get repaired by one
of the many pathways the most
predominant one is the non-homologous
end joining non-homologous end joining
pathway causes in generation of small
insertions or deletions in the DNA upon
repair and that's the insertion and
deletion that this method will
ultimately to tight how okay so we have
transfected the cells into trance wet
theirselves with the CRISPR CRISPR
generated double strand breaks and those
double strand breaks were
repaired through energy J what we do is
then we harvest the cells nice them
using the lysis buffer provided with the
G silicate and in this case you can see
some of the DNA molecules contained some
mismatched in Dells that are highlighted
as red
now this Dino DNA can be here amplified
using the locus specific primers which
will amplify wild-type DNA which was not
modified as well as in DNA that actually
underwent some IND of formation
following this step we can carry this
DNA or rather the PCR product through
simple denaturation and Riaan a duration
cycle denaturation denaturation cycle
because of his random nature will
generate situations where one strand
that contains an Intel might get
annealed with a different strand which
may contain no in doubt
thereby making for these mismatched
bubbles or mismatched hetero duplexes
this mismatched head to duplex formation
is very nicely detected by our detection
enzyme X provided in the kit and the
detection enzyme makes cleavage at the
federal death duplex making leading to
the formation of to cleave DNA molecules
which can be easily visualized by
running the total product onto the gel
shown here in the job schematically as a
cleaved band which runs faster and an
uncut band that's the parental band we
can have an estimate of the total
abundance of cleaved products and that
can give us a measure of the total
amount of cleavage that was generated by
the CRISPR this match
is very simple and easy as I said it
takes only four hours to carry through
however is clear that it does not give
us all the answers to get more answers
we need to resort to sequencing based
methods and I will go through the simple
workflow using next-generation
sequencing to address these questions
once again in this workflow first step
is delivery of the crispers to cells
followed by transfection and
generational transfer yourself would
transfer to cell pool can then be
subjected to PCR amplification as before
and after PCR amplification we can
generate a library of transfected DNA
this library can be taken through the
usual sample preparation steps required
for the next-generation sequencing and
then the prepared sample can be
subjected to next-generation sequencing
using the ion PGM system followed by
sequence analysis Here I am just giving
you a snapshot of several thousand
dreams that are generated by a simple
snapshot can easily tell us that there
are several different insertion and
deletion events that have happened all
the deletions are visible pretty clearly
and I'm highlighting the pan sequence
which is a GG sequence here and the
cleavage site would be somewhere over
here and you can see there are numerous
insertion deletion events that are
centered around the cut side getting a
good call getting an understanding of
the frequency of these events can guide
us in our downstream work with this
information in hand
let's go through
a case study first step in the case
study is of course after assuming that
we have figured out we gene to target
and we designed all the crispers for
that target is first step will be
transaction
so let's translate these cells with the
CRISPR cash nine and we used in this
case like effective in CRISPR naturally
agent to generate DNA double strand
breaks leading to the non-homologous end
joining mediated in terms we took these
transfected cells and subjected them to
genomic leeway detection assay and
quantified the cleaved products and by
quantification we identified the CRISPR
that I'm highlighting as ex5 point to
Pittsburgh as the best performing CRISPR
so we decided to pursue this further
took the transfected cell pool and made
the lysate and use the life state for on
and off target NGS analysis and to
understand the whether this CRISPR
caused any spurious off target cleavage
events in this case there was no off
target cleavage events detected okay so
we have generated the selfhood and
detected the best cleavage creating
CRISPR next is using this cell pool
derived from this CRISPR for generation
of a real stable cell line containing
knockout events for gene of interest
first step is using this tell pool
diluting it and performing limiting
dilution cloning or fact sorting to play
it one or less cell for well in a
96-well plate
after we do that we can just leave the
place alone in a teashop urchin
incubator for a couple of weeks after a
couple of weeks you need to look at this
place
under microscope or visualize them
through many other means to see whether
the colonies are being formed and the
thing to pay attention is to ensure that
we are identifying wells which contain
only one growing colony I'm showing here
the example of two different wells one
of them has only one colony and the
other one has two growing colonies we
want single monoclonal population so we
should be going with the wells that have
only one single growing colony so we let
them grow consolidate them together and
go forward so next step is a simple easy
Sanger sequencing based screen to
identify clones
whose DNA has some kind of endeavor
vents which are easily visualized on a
Sanger sequencing chromatogram by
degeneration of those Peaks which I'm
highlighting here candidate clone has
several Peaks that are degenerated and
overlapping whereas the wild-type shows
nice chromatograph so these candy red
clones
we can pursue further and I did identify
what are the indle events that occurred
winner in this particular situation we
did sequencing of 178 single clones and
identified six potential cones to pursue
further using NGS and in the
next-generation sequencing we identified
and I am showing you example of one
particular clone this clone had
50/50 redistribution so half reads
arising from one allele rest half
arising from another allele with one
bill duration at a 14 base division both
of these deletion events lead to a frame
shift in the reading frame of the Jane
wonderful so this is a very good
positive tone that we can pursue further
now you will ask a question okay this is
good for not out what if we want to just
correct some sequence so that is
achieved by using a suitably designed
donor molecule design of donor molecule
is a different topic which we are not
going to be touching here but there are
webinars or thermo Fisher website which
are available on demand and we can look
at those who understand the best ways to
design donor molecules
we'd love to say we designed a donor
molecule and our goal was to convert an
80 g to g TG in the coding sequence of a
gene
and I'm showing you here to two parallel
examples of two different clones one in
which the ATG was completely converted
to GTG across all reads and in another
situation where the ad G was converted
only partly to GTG and there were some
reads that were still left with ATG and
the fraction of reads that contained ATG
was half gdg perhaps so it looked like
it was the heterozygous change okay now
after this detour we can go back to our
original case study so we perform the
limiting dilution cloning here
identified single blowing growing
colonies single growing colonies were
code through a simple Sanger sequencing
method for presence of in doubt the
candidates that had in delft were scored
further and analyzed by next generation
sequencing for the nature of in-depth
and in our case I just showed you the
example of a single clone which
contained a one base deletion and a 14
based deletion wonderful and those this
particular phone is ready for further
analysis further analysis can be
genotypic and phenotypic as well as
functional I will just go over the
genotypic analysis where we understood
where the deletion was identified the
junction points for the deletion which I
am highlighting highlighting here so
between this red highlighted a and C was
one base relation and that resulting
frameshift led to formation of a stop
codon 17 amino acids downstream in the
other allele where we had 14 based
deletion
again between these red highlighted a
and C's was the 14 bases that got
deleted and let me point out in both of
these cases the junctions of deletions
are a and C sequence but that's just a
coincidence it doesn't always happen so
in the second allele between the judge a
and three verse fourteen bases that got
deleted resulting frameshift led to a
stop codon two amino acids downstream so
we generated a stop codon here both the
alleles of the gene have been converted
in converted to encounter premature stop
codons and therefore lose their function
pretty quickly with that I'm at the
point where I can tell you about all the
various cell engineering services that
Micro provides here no cell line is too
difficult for us we perform a
transaction optimization to identify the
best conditions to deliver genome
editing reagents into the cells then we
can carry out a copy number assay to
understand the copy number of the gene
because the cell lines are generally
heterogeneous so we need to understand
that we can also provide services for on
and off target analysis sequencing of
the target locus to confirm is identity
to a reference genome that is present
for human and mouse and finally we
provide a complete end-to-end cell
engineering service to generate the
mutation or the chain knockout that you
desire in the cell line of your choice
with that we are ready to ask biological
questions using these mutations that we
just made so I will pass over the baton
to China and China can walk us through
the functional aspects of these
mutations
how can we use these cellular models for
asking relevant biological questions so
here is it to you chip knock hello
everyone so once you create these
cellular models let's see how you can
use these to address questions about
functional genomic screening or target
identification so in the next slide here
I want to ground everybody as to why
CRISPR catheline technology is so
exciting for especially for screening
purposes so in reference to what's
currently widely popular the RNA I
mediated gene knockdown CRISPR cache
line technology is the next-generation
tool for functional genomic screening
and as opposed to the and as opposed to
the temporary gene knocked down after
spec assigned technology provides
complete and permanent knockout of gene
expression leading to stronger
phenotypes larger assay window higher
confidence and heads and clearer
verification of the targets let's take a
moment to see what the basically
functional genomics is and target
identification so the goal of functional
genomics is to understand the
relationship between an organism's
genome and its phenotype
whereas target identification is the
process of identifying the direct
molecular target or be it a protein or
nucleic acid of a small molecule or a
specific phenotype
so essentially functional genomics is
done on a larger scale or in
high-throughput mode and why is
functional genomics or target
identification important as Sanjay
they're making disease models from
patient-derived cells or even regular
cell line it's so much has gotten so
much easier with advances in cellular
engineering or genome engineering you
can use these cellular models in
multiple assay formats depending on your
interest and pick a pathway of your
interest and try to identify key genes
or targets in this pathway of interest
and use these in combination especially
for combination therapy to identify
novel drug molecules or use the existing
small molecules or drugs for therapy
purposes and CRISPR cast line system
allows us to do that by specifically
knocking out genes of interest in a
particular pathway or cell signaling
pathway so in my half of the talk I'm
going to focus on three different things
one is I'll talk about how phenotypic
assays can be used to further
investigate a gene knockout model then
I'll talk about in mutagen a lentiviral
based CRISPR libraries for functional
genomic screening and then finally end
my talk with how the lentiviral CRISPR
library especially the kind of library
was used to identify a potential new
therapeutic target for Rob Roy tumors
for the phenotypic profiling of the gene
knockout the model system used in this
case was a TG 5 a knockout saline in you
to SL background and it's shown here on
this slide
this particular highlighted area shows
that we picked one of the clones for a
DG 5 knockout which was a homozygous
knockout it's represented by cloned
and you can see the ad g5 is completely
expression is completely abolished in
this case and the housekeeping gene
shown in green the gab pH is expressed
and these studies were done using this
Alam Excel and site high content imaging
system and before I get into the further
phenotypic assays let's see what role
ATG 5 or it's the autophagy 5 protein
plays in out of Ag so it's shown here in
the complex out of Ag process and it
plays a very important or central role
in out of Ag especially formation of
auto failure zones and two other
proteins lc3 B and P 62 are also
important in the auto focus on formation
and that's shown in this slide here
wherein we are looking to see what
effect the ATG 5 knockout has on the
auto Faygo dome formation and as seen in
this particular plot here we are looking
at LC 3 V spot intensity as plotted on
the y axis and with increasing
concentration of chloroquine you can see
in parental or the scrambled guide RNA
which is letting the nonspecific ion a
teacher self you see good LC 3 V
accumulation and self as determined by
the spot intensity where is in case of
the ATG fine knockout we do not see the
increase in lc3 be intensity indicating
that as you see B does not activate in
these cells similarly in the next step
to auto vehicle so information is the
auto lysosome formation where in the
auto failure zone integrates with
lysosomes and one of the lysosomal
marker is lamp one and you can see on
the y axis
LC 3b and lamp on co-localization is a
plotted and in case of parent or you see
good localized
localization of lttb and lamp one has
shown on by the red line and in ad g5
knockout you do not see this
co-localization indicating the auto
favor zones do not watch with the
lysosomes the next and this particular
image shows what I just described like
in case of in the lower panel where you
see the ad g5 knockout cells you do not
see every LC 3v aggregation upon
chloroquine treatment whereas in case of
parental you do see and then there is
very little o co-localization with lamps
one next we look at the other important
molecule in auto focus on formation P 62
which is in fact it serves as a receptor
to target the ubiquitinated carbo to the
autofit zone and in case of the ATG 5
knockout as seen here what you see is
even before even before treatment with
chloroquine you do see increased levels
of P 62 and that is because it cannot it
does not get degraded because the
cycling or trafficking to lysosomes is
defector in this case so it just
accumulates in the cytoplasm basically
whereas in case of parental it does get
degraded and upon troll Queen treatment
you do see the puncta so essentially in
AD g5 knockout cells the autofit also
information is defective the next thing
we looked at is now in these cells is
the normal cytosolic stress how do these
cells respond to cytosol ex stress as we
know that autophagy is
basically a pro survival mechanism so
are these cells more prone to cytotoxic
stress and if you look at this
particular plot here wearing we looked
at caspase activation using the cell
event caspase-3 7 reagent there is with
increasing concentration of sort of
foreign treatment there is no additional
or there is no the ATG 5 or knockout
cells are not not really extra sensitive
to caspase or to a patatas so indicating
that these do the pathway for the serine
the pathway for cytotoxic stress is not
affected in this case and on the plot on
the right hand side we looked at DNA
damage using a depe site and you can see
with increasing concentration of
etoposide we do not see increase in DNA
damage or the DNA damage is comparable
to that seen in the parental or
wild-type cells and this DNA damage was
detected using the phosphorylated h2ax
antibody and the same thing is shown in
images below then you can see with 100
micro molar etoposide treatment the
activation our levels of pH 2ax are
comparable in both cell types ATG
knockout as well as parental this
indicates that basically ATG fire
knockout cells it just have defect in
the autofill zone information so this is
one of the ways we're in how you can
investigate the phenotypic effect also
gene knockout next I will move on to
talking about the lentiviral base CRISPR
libraries for functional genomic
screening and at the land
Videl accessible libraries come in two
different formats
one is the Lenti or rate whisper library
as the name suggests these are basically
arrayed in 96-well format and up to 80
genes or 80 targets are provided on one
plate where the lengthy pool CRISPR
libraries are basically pulled libraries
and in this case in the lady pool
library each target has ten guide RNA
and in case of the Lenti or a library
each target has four guide RNA and these
four diaries are pooled in the single
well so given and the ninety or a format
because these are arrayed and you
already know the identity of the target
in the single well you can use these
libraries for plate based assays or
high-content assays where as the pool
library is mainly used for cell survival
acids and there is less upfront work for
the pool library but a lot of back end
work involving deep sequencing for when
you use the pool library whereas for the
lengthy array it's less back-end work as
you already know the identities of the
target so in our catalog we have 17 sub
libraries based on gene families and
functional biology and in addition to
these 70 s of libraries you also have
druggable genome and the whole genome
and here is the list of all the 19
different libraries that we have in our
catalog and this particular column shows
the different number of genes that are
covered under each sub library and the
corresponding number of guide RNA so
essentially it will be four times the
number of genes this particular slide
shows the vector construct design for
both the
90 cash 9 and the lengthy guide RNA on
the right hand side here this particular
design for a lengthy cast 9 is as you
can see the cast 9 is driven by EF 1 as
for promoter and is also linked to the
plasticity in markers using the self
saving to a peptide and the lengthy
guide RNA in here the the guide RNA as
such is driven by the u6 promoter and it
also carries a selection marker pure of
mice and that's driven by EF 1 alpha
promoter and I would like to point out
one thing in here for the lengthy guide
RNA we do have not intentionally used
any fluorescent markers on here just so
that when people use it for SES assays
you don't lose one channel for during
detection and to address that lack of a
fluorescent marker in the guide RNA we
also provide controls specifically the
hprt and the scrambled basically a
negative control that have the GFP
marker on there and you can use this for
detecting transduction efficiency and
also as negative controls in the assay
this particular slide further analyzes
how efficient the these lentiviral preps
are and Sanjay already went over how the
efficiency is detected where GCD and in
this case and the same thing is affected
so basically HD 1080 cells were tens
views with some of these example
proteins that are shown here and this
was dual particle transduction so cash
nine
and Landy guides what Co tends to use
and Pyramus and selectors for five days
and the GCD assay was run on these
samples and you can see for all the
targets we get more than we get more
than 80% in the whole formation or gene
knockout this next slide gives an
overview of CRISPR screening so and in
in terms of screening you can either use
dual particle construction like cache
line and the guide RNA quotients to use
and look at the effect or alternatively
if you have a bigger screen you can
always generate a cache line stable line
and then just use guide RNA for
transduction and depending on if you use
pool or clonal selection it can range
anywhere from 6 to 12 weeks the next
milestone then is a transaction and
assay optimization and this is one of
the crucial pieces of screening because
unless you confirm that your assay is
working fine all your conditions you are
using are fine sometimes like if you
just move forward with screening it
might not yield useful data so it's in
the transaction and as the optimization
is a key step in any screening process
so once you have that optimized which
takes about roughly about three weeks
and it depends on the assay that you are
using and the controls once you have
that optimized then you move on to the
actual library screening are followed by
validation and depending on the library
size and the assay format again these
can take anywhere from two to five weeks
and at thermo Fisher here we offer this
as a service next I'll talk about a case
study where and we used the invitation
lanty array libraries and the pie norm
library for
looking at NF kappa-b signaling pathway
and for this we used our one of our
sensor asses in any one eighty cell
background and shown here in on the left
hand side is the simplistic view of the
NF kappa-b activation in this align upon
activation by a VR TNF alpha the TNF
alpha would upon activation of TNF our
one receptor we are a TNF you get
downstream activation of trad ikk alpha
further leading to activation of NF
Kappa beta which they Cassidy which then
translocates to the nucleus and activate
a beta lactamase gene so the cells and
so align expresses a beta lactamase
reporter under under control of NF
kappa-b
response promoter so once an escape of a
is activated it transmits to the nucleus
and activates beta lactamase and the way
we detect this is using a life blazer
substrate and when the cells are loaded
with life blazer substrate if there is
no beta lactamase production the library
the substrate is intact and it basically
works on fed based mechanism so when you
excite the substrate at four or nine
eight m/s in the Prine range
so essentially green cells means no
activation of the pathway but when beta
lactamase is present and due to
activation of the pathway it reads the
beta-lactam ring in this life blazer
substrate and because the ring is
cleaved when you activate the substrate
at four or nine eight m/s in the blue
range so essentially blue cells means
the pathway is active so just in the
next few slides you should remember that
green is pathway
not activated and blue as pathways
activated and we look at the blue-green
ratio for further analysis and this
particular slide summarizes how we go
about optimizing the assay for
downstream screening the top panel here
shows how different self-healing density
is compared to using different my so we
used a thousand cells per well or two
thousand cells power and for different
mo eyes and you can see that my of two
which is shown by the blue bar here is
the optimal because using higher my does
not provide any additional advantage so
to save on the reagents and my is like
the optimal one to go with and the next
condition that we looked at was spin
operation this is like when we
transducers or overlay the cells with
LAN dividers and spin it at high speeds
of like to 2500 for 30 minutes so at N
certain cell types this has shown to be
useful so we wanted to see if it is an
appellation is needed in this case or
not and when we compared to inoculation
is shown by the red bars here and when
you compare it to no spin operation
shown by the blue bar in the middle plot
you can see that it was very comparable
and we also compared like different days
reading at day 5 and day 8 so
essentially there was no difference
between day 5 and day 8 and you can have
hourly readout of this assay and spanner
collection as you can see the blue bar
and the red bars compared really well so
it did not have any additional benefit
so in this case it's optional similarly
with puro myosin selection and it
depends on the construction efficiency
if your transduction efficiency is
really good you do not need any
antibiotic selection which is shown in
this case like the red bar is
we're in Purim Ison was the
self-selected mr. Amash and the blue bar
is a shows there no selection was added
to the self and again in this case they
do compare very well that means the
transduction efficiency in this case is
so high that you don't really need to
add selection and then again reading at
day five day nine which really did not
make any difference that means a shorter
time frame for assay is just fine
so having optimized all these conditions
we then further validated the known
targets in this and a Kappa B pathway
and followed the protocol that's listed
here in the workflow on the top wherein
we take the we take the clone that we
generated that stable he expresses
catheline we see sours
that is they want and on day two we
transduce it with the guide RNA and a
four days after transduction we on day 5
we add TNF alpha stem and read the
blue-green ratio and shown below here
are the images from the control samples
and you can see this Campbell an hpid
which are negative control you see that
the pathway is active and when we treat
the cells with guide RNA targeting PLA
which is like a technical control if you
knock out the reporter you should not
see any signaling or activation of the
pathway so if we indeed don't see any
activation of the pathway in this BL a
slide and the same thing is true when we
knock out a TNF r1 you do not see
activation of the pathway because if the
receptor itself is knocked out you
should not ideally see any downstream
effect and then ikk alpha and Tran which
are the partials now we see little bit
of activation but mostly the pathway is
inhibited so having confirmed this we
then went on to fourth or value
if what we are seeing in the functional
assay and does it correlate to what is
happening at the genome level and here
you can see on in the top plot we have
shown trad treat yourself and ikk alpha
knocked out ourselves and the Intel
formation is was determined by NGS assay
and you can see it's really very highly
efficient and L formation more than 80%
in both cases and when we looked at the
protein level in fact in these cells
as shown in the lower prod you do see
good knockout of these both proteins and
then we looked at the functional assay
the entire formation really translates
well to the functional assay as well
wherein we see more than 85% inhibition
of the pathway or beta lactamase
activation and the images on the top
show the same thing this is a secondary
verification says somebody is I mean if
you are not interested in looking at the
beta lactamase and pathway or beta
lactamase reporter you can also use this
system to study via ATS or imaging
system and on the on the right hand side
plot here I mean right hand side panel
images what you are seeing is an escape
of a translocation to the nucleus upon
tnf-alpha activation that's shown in the
lower half of the left hand side panel
and in the cells that are tried knocked
out or ikk alpha knocked out you do not
see this NF kappa-b tense location to
the nucleus indicating that the pathway
is disrupted on the right hand side
panel we looked at we looked at
the ikk alpha phosphotase
I kick an alpha activation using
phosphorylated anti phosphorylated ikk
alpha antibody and you can see in the
parent or the no guide RNA treated cells
you do see ikk as a phosphorylation upon
TNF alpha treatment whereas in ikk alpha
knockout cells you do not see that
activation upon TNF alpha stimulation so
next after having thoroughly validated
the system we went on to the actual
screen wherein we used 384-well format
for screening and all the parameters
that we had previously confirmed the
including optimization and the controls
that are listed in here basically HP
idea- control VLA as a technical and
control technical control and the
pathway control
Seaforth ikk alpha and TNF r1 and for
this we screen the whole kinam library
that consists of eight hundred and forty
targets and we use the same as a
protocol that I previously described
which is a 5-day protocol and this was
the plate layout that we used
so we screened about 56 targets on each
single 384-well plate along with the
controls so the ten and half plates for
the Chi known library the nine ten and
half 96-well plates of the kind on
libraries and translates to 15 384 well
plates and the data from the controls
from these 384 well plate is shown here
on this plot which looks at the
interplay 2 reproducibility and you can
see that there are 15 plus 15 dots for
each of the plots and it is really very
tight showing that this assay is robust
and works really well for each of the
commercially for the control strategy
and fr1 DLA and this is what the actual
final screening data looks
so plotted here on the y axis is percent
activation of the pathway and the x-axis
is the number of samples and shown here
on this particular right-hand side plot
is the same controls what you should
what you see on the left hand side are
just as a reference point and depending
on the reference point then you drew
that arbitrary red line which separates
the true negatives from the positive
heads and as you can see some of the
colored dots that are shown on the plot
like the plk for chop neck 40k and one
are the known very well characterized
players in the NF kappa-b pathway so we
did identify already known and along
with some of the unique targets so
having identified 75 or so heads it
ranged from cell surface molecules to
molecules involved in cell cycle
regulation we did conform some of the
other heads using small molecules
wherever we could find smaller molecule
available for a particular target we
validated that and that data is shown in
this plot here on the right hand side
lower right hand side then we confirm
the PK and 1p l k4 and some other
targets we did confirm that it was
indeed a target for this particular
pathway next we went on to further
validate these heads using SI RNA and
shown here in this plot on y axis is the
BL a pathway inhibition and on the x
axis its the knockdown of the particular
target gene using TaqMan gene expression
assays and you can see using these si
RNA we got pretty good knockdown for
most of the targets
and in some cases the effect on the VLA
inhibition was really good but in some
for some targets it was not that
impressive when we compared this data to
what it looks like with CRISPR and shown
here here sorry on the right hand side
plot on on y-axis is si RNA mediated
inhibition and on x axis is the CRISPR
mediated inhibition and you can see
first and some of these targets that are
on the extreme right hand side of the
plot are some of the very well
characterized molecules or targets in
the pathway so no wonder they show up in
both stress for an SI RNA mediated there
are some of the other ones that are
really subtle or do not show up in SI
RNA the one in around that 50 percent
mark around in the whispered screening I
really really low in case of SI RNA
mediated inhibition so it D could have
been easily missed in our si RNA screen
but the CRISPR screen picks it up
indicating that the CRISPR
is more kissable knockout is more
penetrant as compared to the SI RNA not
done next quickly I just want to talk
about how these CRISPR libraries were
used to identify a new therapeutic
target in case of tabloid tumors one of
our collaborators of the Samoan trainee
at Northwestern she did this study and
using our LNT excuse me 90 CRISPR
library she identified plk 4 as a target
for the malignant Reptoid tumors and
this work was published earlier this
year just reduced of data from the study
the middle plot here shows one of the
results from a Samoan screening and what
you see here is the South that
were plk for knocked-out showed the
slowest cell growth as compared to any
other targets that she looked at this
indicated that the cell growth was
inhibited if pha-4
was knocked out and we further confirmed
that in these cells were plk 4 was
knocked out in fact you see on the
extreme right hand side you see good in
their formation indicating that the gene
shows very high efficiency of knockout
and she further confirmed the slow
growth rate using ki-67 or cell
proliferation marker and uses do see
significant difference between ourselves
never in the PRK for knock knock was
knocked out it was significantly the
proliferation rate was significantly
different as compared to the parent of
cell line or just cache line expressing
oneself and on the extreme right hand
side it is a clonal Jenica say when you
look at clone formation so what you see
here on the two on the left hand side
plate is just the parental cells mon
cache line cells and on the left hand
side right hand side is mon cells where
in the p lk 4 is knocked out and you see
very few colonies formed there so one of
the the interesting thing is why wasn't
PL k 4 picked out in this case prior to
Simone's analysis and this particular
plot here alludes to that so if you look
at PR k for expansion in the Reptoid
tumors or the atypical and territory
Reptoid tumors it is the PMF for
expansion is not very high or is not
significantly higher as compared to
other
embryonal brain tumors but it is
significant
hi as compared to the non embryonal
brain tumors so it's easy for it to have
been missed but because using CRISPR and
total knockout of the gene then helps to
identify that as a target so what's him
under in this case is she collaborated
with one of the group up in Toronto
Canada when in they had already
identified a plk four inhibitor the see
I four zero zero nine four as one of the
molecule for a breast cancer treatment
and it was already in clinical trial so
she used this to see what effect it has
on the 8080 tumors and shown here on the
right hand side in the flow no genic
assay then the the compound treated
cells do so inhibition of growth or no
colony formation and that was true
across all those cell lines like bt 12
g4 0 1 or bt 16 the other adrd cell
lines so it has the CFI molecule has a
true potential of being used as a drug
for treatment of this 8080 tumors
so in summary thermo fisher at Thermo
Fisher Scientific we offer full workflow
solutions for editing and functional
genomic needs though stressful libraries
as I talked about our powerful and high
throughput loss of function screening
tool for target identification and
although we offer like the 19 libraries
that are listed in our catalog the
blissful libraries are built in such a
fashion that they are flexible and if
needed we can make a custom library ask
for your need so you can put together a
custom library if needed
so essentially we have all the tools
that you need for your genome editing
and screening efforts and make a big
impact on drug discovery and your
screening efforts last but not the least
I would like to remind you that we have
another event on November 9th
it's the 24 hours of Spencer so please
feel free to register for this event and
it's again it's on November 9th and the
registration is free and thank you for
your time and attention thank you so
much
Etna and Flonne ji for that informative
presentation I now want to turn to our
audience for the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have any questions you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on that green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window type
your questions into the box that appear
on the screen and click that send button
will answer as many questions as we have
time for today so let's take a look at
our audience questions that are already
coming in our first question is directed
to you Tecna what's the advantage of
using linty wheel vectors compared to
you plasmids and AAV so the key
advantage of using lentiviral system is
mainly in cell types that are hard to
transact or tense and yeah hi -
inspector tends to use so and then even
primary cells or non-dividing cells so
essentially it can be used across a
broad range of cell types that's what I
see as a key advantage and lower my you
know most of cell types would you can
get away with using lower my or
multiplicity of infection that you use
for 10 sec transaction is all thank you
and here's another question actually for
you as well
what the
et g5 do ad g5 is one of the key
components that's involved in art of Ag
so it is involved in it is mainly the
primary role is it's in the auto film
formation well it's on keyboard it's one
of the core protein okay thank you
and thank you again audience we have
great questions coming in from all over
the world here's our next question and
then this one's for you Sanji you spoke
a lot of the about a lot of different
methods to detect the edit what methods
do you find that are best or use the
most often and why actually we use most
of the methods it's just that there are
certain methods which are easy to pursue
to ask simple questions for example I
showed the gel-based genomically weight
detection method that is a very easy
method to ask very preliminary questions
like okay if I designed more than one
editing agent let's say we designed
three crispers which one worked best
that but that particular question can be
very quickly answered by genomically
which detection assay but if you are
asking more detailed questions for
example whether the intended change that
we wanted to introduce into the cells
was introduced and what was the
frequency of introduction of that change
that question will be answered by
sequencing so there are different places
where both both of these different
methods are applicable one is for simple
asking a yes-or-no question
and the second will be answering some
more details and in test questions
wonderful thank you so much fun G and
here is another question for you
excuse me I'm sorry let me pull it up
here I apologize it is all of a sudden
not shilling
the next question is actually for you
Savannah how will you apply this study a
medallion or Mendelian disease like
cystic fibrosis
oh that's a tough one so actually it's a
interesting question right we can
actually address things like cystic
fibrosis cystic fibrosis is one of the
key determinants of cystic fibrosis is a
mutation a frameshift mutation is CFTR
gene so we can in fact design take
wild-type cells design the appropriate
crispers and appropriate donor DNA's and
create the mutation in the wild-type
CFTR gene and ask the relevant
biological questions depending on the
tissue where it's derived from and the
mutation the zygosity of mutation that's
introduced we can in fact address and
ask the relevant biological question in
this context thank you so much and
here's um one more question that we have
time for today and again I want to thank
our audience for their participation our
next question is directed to you Sanji
what has been your success rate for
genome editing
are there any cell lines that are more
challenging or difficult to edit it
actually is always a mixed bag in terms
of success we have had a very high
degree of success in our genome editing
experiments however success is again
defined by the endpoint whether we were
able to obtain the desired result
however that side there are cell lines
which are difficult to edit and there
are cell lines which are derived from
blood as well as brain they tend to be
difficult to deliver
and so delivery of editing agent if that
is compromised of course that final end
result will be that there will be low
level of editing now that is said that
said it will only tell us that the
amount of editing events within those
settler populations is low again that
informs us that the number of clones
that we will have to screen for final
outcomes will be correspondingly larger
so when we are talking about
understanding the nature and frequency
of editing events within a pool the
reason why we do that
at that level and in that much depth is
to understand what is the total number
of editing events happening in the total
cellular population and that informs us
how many clones we should be screening
once we have got that number we can
screen the appropriate number of clones
to achieve the final outcome so answer
is yes we can
in fact get the outcome it's only the
amount of labor that goes into getting
to the final outcome that changes the
question Thank You Sanjay and shot not
in Swansea thank you so much for your
presentation today audience members we
appreciate your live participation in
any of your other questions will be
answered via email by thermo Fisher
Scientific I'd also like to thank Thermo
Fisher Scientific for sponsoring today's
educational webcast and lab roots for
making it possible for more information
you can visit our sponsor at thermo
Fisher com before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through April of 2018 you'll receive an
email from lab roots letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues soon as May
today's live event that's all for now
and thank you so much for joining us
thank you shut 'no thank you Sanjay we
hope to see everyone again soon goodbye
bye-bye
you